okay for people who are joining this
live stream we are talking about design
of chemistry functionality modern
language and
we are talking about
template reaction and reaction apply
a representation of chemical reactions
and
uh where did we get to last time
well so um
we got stuck on the uh the how you label
the atoms on the the left and the right
side of the reaction okay and so we've
come back with a couple of alternative
um methods for for labeling them um
so you have uh in the reaction smarts
that you see there
okay uh you might need to open this up
in the prototype build uh if you want to
run these things i should have brought
that up beforehand
um
the atoms are given numbers do the
numbers have to be consecutive or could
i put it i do not
okay which means
12 or something in there if i wanted to
yes
which can make it confusing because in
general wolfram language uh molecule you
refer to the atoms by their index by
their number
and so uh having two so what working
responses allow one to do as that as the
designator of the molecules do they have
to be numbers or could they be anything
i want
let's see for the for the um
for the mapping number or in the smart
string could i call that a or something
oh no
so it has to be a number right
at least in their version of smarts yeah
okay and in this formatting
the fact that it says oh colon three
and that's right talk to the design
group about these about these blobs here
no as we discussed
okay so you will do that absolutely
okay and i mean once we decide on an
alternate uh scheme besides colon number
then the plots will change accordingly
um and if if we have these uh this hover
effect and possibly you don't need the
uh um the visible
the visual cue there because if it's not
something as simple as a number then it
could get
unwieldy to to put them all there
let's cross that bridge in a moment okay
okay and as i said last time we should
also talk about using this kind of
hovering thing
on ordinary patterns
right did did somebody take that
that will be for the user assistance
crew did somebody take that
not that i know of oh come on
who's project managing here
is it
we didn't we didn't have one last time
so we have kristin here now so we'll get
that to user assistance
okay
okay
all right so
okay
so the two alternates yeah i see it i
see it
but now
the use of the pattern on the right hand
side here
i don't even understand this this is so
we have a pattern on the left and a
pattern on the right
and in this case the pattern on the
right does not re-repeat the type of
atom
correct
more like our ordinary pattern variables
but now if if we were to reverse this
reaction
we would need to know how to redo
the uh the bound variable stuff
right in general these things um aren't
necessarily reversible because you can
write
much more
different kinds of patterns on the left
and the right hand side of the what way
it's not one-to-one it's not one-to-one
stephen
i just want to say like the patterns on
the left can be vague they could be a
carbon or a nitrogen or something but on
the right we'll we should i don't know
if it's there yet but it should i get it
i understand i understand i understand
so it's going to be it's going to pick
up whatever it was on the left
going to a definite thing on the right
and so this would be how does smarts
deal with the fact that there could be
multiple things on the left and then
when it refers to it on the right does
it have to repeat that alternative from
the left on the right if you put in
asterisk um or in language if you put an
underscore
uh it it picks it just that is the same
thing as like inherited uh
and so we would
we would use inherited when possible or
parse it so that's the case
that
so i mean what we need is a name
and
that you know it is superfluous
there's never a point
okay question question if the left-hand
side contains carbon nitrogen or oxygen
right and the right hand side no i mean
what am i talking about this is not a
formal thing this is a thing which at
actual atoms so whatever was on the left
better be on the right you know
alchemists be damned you can't transmute
it
right i thought you can in smart
well i mean march you can but we don't
have to do that in a lab you definitely
can't transmute but if we're talking
about uh like a an op function that that
operates on like molecule objects and
transforms them
it's you could write it just to where it
changes the carbon into okay okay but
but wait a second if i say this
that's just going to be garbage and
would anybody want to do that is there a
good reason to want to do that
other than that you're about to make a
mistake
let's see um
i
i don't know that i would but i imagine
the users will why why why would they do
that
there's no possible reaction that this
could represent right it's either if
it's carbon on the left it cannot be
nitrogen on the right
let's see so if you're trying so these
the template reaction can be used to
model
one specific reaction but it can also be
used to perform arbitrary
transformations on a molecule object
or almost
i see so that's a completely different
thing so that is then transmuting that
is a true graph rewriting in which you
are potentially replacing the
carbon-based life form of the
silicon-based life form
kind of thing is that the idea yeah
i mean and so let's move on
so this isn't a reaction this is a
pattern if that's what you're saying
this is a you know a chemical rule
basically
that says blah blah blah goes to blah
blah blah
yes
okay which is not the same as a chemical
reaction a chemical reaction cannot
transmute carbon to nitrogen
but a chemical rule in which you're
making a substitution in a molecule
absolutely could
but don't we already have
molecule what was it called molecule
modified
has replaced substructure
which can do a lot
but essentially uh
to a certain extent you need to have
callbacks like if you want to replace a
substructure and insert atoms in the
middle of it
and rearrange the the bonding then it
can only go so far
well i don't know what i would do is
just turn the whole thing into a graph
and do whatever graph operations i can
on it and then take it back
graph doesn't support annotation
sufficiently no no hold on stop uh no i
mean in the in under the hood we are we
do have it as a graph and we what
aspects of graph don't support enough
annotations for stereochemistry or
something or what well no it's more even
the atoms they get lost
well it's that uh you can't do like um
let's see
subs structure have you reported that as
a bug
should we shall we see if we can get
charles in this meeting please uh
not at the moment i don't i mean we have
asked them about uh including let's see
if we can could somebody please try and
get charles on this meeting
yeah yep i can get them
um
look it's not tempting reaction because
we have chemical reaction for chemical
reactions everything's specified and
here we are a little bit looser this
stuff no no you're missing the point if
you're telling me that you can replace
carbon by silicone it is not a freaking
chemical reaction okay i mean let's
ignore that like that i'm not ignoring
that because you told me that that was a
thing you could expect to do with a
smart string is it or is it not
absolutely but it's it's it's not the
important ones i don't think okay but we
don't want to make that mistake
right now we're pandering to the smarts
format
okay which you know it's a nice
convenient format
but whether we want a panda to that
extent i don't know
okay so so my point here is
is what we're doing a transformation
between molecules or is it
a
representation of a physically
realizable chemical reaction
the first
it's an arbitrary transformation between
molecules
right so people like chemists write
these reactions i've found a few
collections in the in the wild and i
mean in general they're often they might
oftentimes be trying to represent
something that is synthesizable like if
you start with this
starting material
we know
i have a copy of this book called name
reactions oh no no
no that's going to have real reactions
in it sure but i don't i i don't want to
get uh get uh too far here i mean i just
wanted to say that like
you you'll have a series of reactions
that happen step after step after step
and you don't want to write
a computer um like a function that that
simulates every step of that you just
want to skip to the end you want to get
know what could i produce if i have
these molecules of starting materials
okay
and so what does that have to do with
this so
that
in that way you would write a a template
reaction that pulled uh uh
oxygen atoms out of the ether
that they just appear on the right hand
side because you know that
in these steps they could be they could
come okay
okay that's useful okay
and likewise something from the left
could just disappear because it goes
into the you know
the solvent or you know just sort of
floats away
exactly
okay
so you're representing you know ignore
the carbon dioxide that you're producing
or something
is that right people would yeah okay
so it really isn't a reaction it's a
it's a transformation i mean it's more
like a chemical transformation of some
kind
right i mean i yeah
um it's really not a reaction
well so i tend to think of it as
related to reaction because with the
template reaction if you gave it then a
list of molecules
it would spit back a list of products
the reaction applies
chemical transformation
it's not a reaction look
you're basically telling me this thing
is not a physically realizable reaction
necessarily it is merely a
representation of a transformation from
one chemical to others
that's fair
yeah okay so let's let's now discuss
in that chemical transformation we have
named pieces
of the left-hand side molecule and in
principle
smarts notwithstanding we could name a
whole
what are we calling them what do you
call them radical what is what are they
called p chunk of molecule what are
those things called the r's
okay all right you could you could i
don't know whether smart supports it but
there's no reason you couldn't make just
like if i look at the name reaction book
okay it commonly has an r
in the in the sort of formula that gives
for a reaction is that is that right
okay
but smarts
is or is not supporting that
you can do that right
i mean so an r just means anything
no no no no no no it doesn't mean a
single atom
but it does a star
in wolf language and atom with an
underscore
no no no no no no that's not a that is a
single atom a carbon a nitrogen whatever
else
an r as i understand it in like the name
reaction book
means any random functional groupie
thing hanging off the end that could be
six atoms in size
so what i'm asking is in smarts can you
represent a six atom functional group
somewhere
as a pattern variable
in principle
yeah uh generally in smarts though you
don't worry about those radicals they
just get carried along based on how they
were attached to the atoms that are
specified
okay let's be specific let me look up um
you know
give me a j random name reaction
with um
what's all that reaction
like the one we're seeing right now
that's
okay here we go i've got a random one i
just looked it up on a random website
okay here it is
these are all your personal friends i
understand these reactions i i don't
know what um okay so here's an example
so here we've got r r prime r double
prime
okay
and very bizarrely we have multiple
copies of r on the right hand side
yeah because there are two of those
two instances of those to make that
bigger thing
okay
even more confusing okay go ahead
okay so that now we would like to have a
representation of this
kind of thing right which is challenging
even in the in that that too is really
really puts a wrench in the whole thing
okay so but what i'm trying to
understand is the pattern variables that
we want should be able to represent
things like these r's in here
how do we represent that right now
so if we if i say molecule
and um
you know i've got my bonds and so on if
i if i have that
well right now we're numbering the bond
is is based on the number
of that thing but what i'm going to want
to do is i'm going to want to have not
an atom but this radical where instead
am i not
we're trying to solve this problem i
understand whether or not
i put the name chemical reaction alpha
we have these things on
you have game communication alphas
i see you think this misses steven's
point
uh
bob correct me if i'm wrong but
if we write the smarts for this one we
just need to represent the two separate
instances of the carbonyl and make sure
there's a crf
engine hanging out
right
before writing the smarts for this
i i don't know i have to reconnect my
internet is being unstable i'm hearing
everybody come in and out up
in a moment
um
okay but you got the point that the
natural way to do this would be to have
a molecule in which instead of an atom
we have some representation of this r
thing am i correct it is not obvious
that this is still a molecule
this is a little bit like chemical
reaction template reaction right this is
in my opinion they're no longer a
it represents a whole family but in a
general sense it's just a pattern right
yeah right so i so i don't understand i
mean so so that is r r prime i mean they
might represent functional groups or
whatnot but in the the graph that is
that molecule pattern they're just an
atom
how do we what what are molecule
patterns right now
what can we put in the molecule you
could use an r
and well
let's implement that you should be able
to type r there
so in this molecule
and this thing here
i can normally i do that and i would get
this okay so now let's say i put an r
i i mean i put a fish here instead
okay
what happens if i put an r there instead
oh my gosh
so r is a special tag
for
for molecule pattern
if what about if i put an r prime here
like they did in that example let's go
oh wow
wow
if i say
r
hello
oh wow
what the heck is it doing here
can somebody explain
where exactly in its documentation does
it say anything about any weird behavior
like this
i don't like you're going in and out on
me what weird behavior are you seeing
here i mean no i wouldn't expect once
you reconnect your can can you reconnect
or can you call in at least on audio on
a cell phone or something
okay so so
something is very wrong here look
okay molecule pattern does not document
anything special that it does and i
don't know exactly what that
what the hell is prop arrow value doing
here with that being in that font what's
what's going on here
yeah this one this one that should be
fixed
okay but but even so
what's happening what is r
the same as asterisk it just means but
why is it being treated especially and
the documentation for molecule pattern
doesn't say anything about that
i don't understand why this is a pattern
anymore okay so it's a pattern that has
alternatives but beyond that this does
not define how this manages to be a
pattern but in fact you're telling me
that r
mysteriously the letter r
is
a um
uh
you know
represents a wild card atom
or or or wild card functional group or
whatever
right that's what you're telling me
which is not documented anyway here
yes so in a molecule pattern you can
have a wild card functional group which
you cannot have in a molecule itself
all you want to be able to do in a month
but in the molecule itself you want to
be able to label atoms
but in a molecule pattern you want to be
able to have a random functional group
hanging off it is that correct
am i correct or not
what's
let's see so you can put an r inside a
molecule um and it'll just it'll just be
an r it'll just display as an r
um
okay look
look what's the difference between
molecule and molecule pattern
let's see so in a molecule pattern you
could specify a an atom as being carbon
or nitrogen okay so you've got
alternatives i said that already okay in
addition to alternatives do you have
wild cards
yes
okay but you don't have it you just told
me you can put an r into molecule as
well
so what's the difference between rn
molecule and an rn molecule pattern
i don't know i mean i don't well who who
wrote does there need to be one i don't
who wrote this i mean you're telling me
does there need to be a difference
okay look molecule pattern the question
is i'm sorry if you if you're
if you're making
look
first of all
is it the case that in molecule pattern
that you match an arbitrary functional
group with an r
when you use a replace with a molecule
pattern
does r match an arbitrary functional
group
no i don't what does it mean i
let's see r is in there just for
convenience because users are going to
type it i've never put all that much
thought into it
um but you made it represent it you
represent it as a star yeah
yes but it doesn't mean a wild card even
though it's represented as a star wait
how do you know it doesn't mean in our
wild card because you just told me it
didn't mean a wild card you you told me
it doesn't mean something where if i
say
you know does this pattern molecule
pattern match
look if i want to know whether some
random thing with some random you know
functional group hanging off here
matches this pattern can i find that
with molecule pattern
yes so you could um let's see you would
do molecule contains q of some molecule
with uh with a molecule pattern
containing r's and it would say either
yes or no yeah but but so r is a wild
card r represents any functional group
correct yes
okay so it is a wild card but in
molecule it is not a wild card if i did
the same thing molecule contains q
and then i put instead of a molecule
pattern i put a molecule there it would
fail it says there's not specifically an
r there so i will not match it is that
correct
that seems reasonable i'm not certain
well it's
you're not saying that's what it does
right okay fine but this is what we're
trying to clean up right now
okay
so you know what we clearly need so
in a molecule and
like in a graph
we're going to need a notion of pattern
variables for a molecule for a graph
okay and what type of pattern variables
do we have well
let me save this before we lose it
completely
um
oh gosh where do i have the
uh chemical
chemical structure i don't know
um
okay
so
what we've got
for a graph for a molecule we have the
possibility that individual nodes
so types of patterns
right one thing is
individual nodes
are substitutable
right
does that make sense so that's the case
of carbon or nitrogen or oxygen or it's
the case of
x colon
uh
to a degree they're substitutable as
long as they have the same number of
connections
it depends on what you want to do with
it too no no no i i i'm trying to define
we're going to have a a
okay we're trying to define a
a pattern a graph pattern
okay and one possibility
i'm so confused here
i'm a little bit confused that like i
see i believe where you are going but
then the screw in things like molecule q
and graphq
because they are absolute objects oh
yeah we'll worry about that in a minute
we'll worry about that in a minute and
maybe what we have is that molecule
pattern is what we use for all of these
cases
okay
okay so you're trying to shoehorn the
fact that you can have a molecule that
happens to have labeled atoms
okay that does not
affect its molecule-ness if you
understand what i'm saying but as soon
as you have carbon or nitrogen or oxygen
you blew up its molecule-ness i would
argue this way
yes i agree you agree with that yeah
okay yeah that's what i think too
right so so there is a special case
of
labeling atoms
where that is purely the human is
labeling the atoms it doesn't affect
the physical molecule-ness of the
underlying object
and so we want a notation for that
but we also want a notation for the case
where we're representing things like
this
okay which i would have expected to be
more like the molecule pattern story
probably or to be able to put something
as a courtesy
into a molecule and have it puff itself
out into a molecule pattern
that is
if there was a i don't know what the
right name for it is but you know if
there was a um
this is a bad idea but as such but let's
imagine that you could type molecule a
functional group blah blah blah blah
in there and that then this would puff
itself out to a molecule pattern
so that the fact that it you know you
type it in as a molecule is merely a
courtesy
does that make sense
just to make sure i follow what's going
on so you build your molecule and as
soon as you have a functional group or
an r floating around boom that
immediately pops you over to a molecule
pattern yes that's what i'm suggesting i
mean that would
that's just a minor convenience but go
ahead what you're going to say okay um
as far as uh different kinds of atoms at
a position go when you're doing a
crystal structure determination
depending on your resolution you might
not know if it's a nitrogen or an oxygen
at a given location in the crystal
you've got electron density there
but you don't know exactly what it is
and a lot of times they report them as
it's this or it's that or metals very
common
you have a mixture of you know yeah i
get it yeah i get it i mean on minerals
and things i've seen yes and minerals
yeah yeah it could be cadmium it could
be nickel or whatever great so you're
telling me that that's not a molecule
it's a molecule pattern and that's fine
right i i no i was just bringing this up
as an example of where
most people chemists would think of it
as
a molecule
but there's some uncertainty about it so
how do we represent that
calling it a pattern doesn't seem to be
quite right
well i don't know i'm not sure that it's
wrong to call it a pattern i mean i
think that it's more complicated in some
of these mineral things where you have
these fractional you know uh whatever
the the fractional occupancy
yeah right the molecule is the wrong uh
container for that for this okay well
okay so we'll put crystals aside for now
yes
okay but but i want to come back to
this
okay
so we've got different various different
cases one case is we've got essentially
graph rewriting
okay this thing here
is a graph rewriting story that in this
notation is absolutely appalling
notation here
right or i mean it can get away with it
i suppose because
wow this is really funky notation
because that r is guaranteed to be the
same because it's two copies of the same
graph basically yes that's correct yes
yep what a weird situation all right i'm
going to pick up another name reaction
here we've been using that notation for
either hundreds of years
at least
not hundreds
hundreds
okay but nobody's complained
until now
well but no this really gets actually
when i was teaching this came up this
really gets to the point that we do that
by
this is a way of lighting all the other
information that is not actively
important to the bonds that are forming
and breaking in this particular reaction
it's a way of just a lighting an
enormous amount of information right you
focus on the important parts here that's
what you do yeah so explain this one to
me what's that r sub three doing
there are three copies of it right
there are three copies of our prime on
that silicon
because silicon has four things needs to
have four things attached to it so three
of that are the three of them are prime
and then that
in in our language for example
this
is very different from
uh
you know r colon blank blank blank
so which is it in this case
are they all identical yes yes they
should be three identical
that's what that means there
so three of the same three of them
exactly three are the same thing
trimethyl you could also have
but you could also have this could you
not where there are three different
things hanging off yes
you could sometimes they make them with
two of one kind of group and a third of
a different
okay fine depending on the type of
protection you want to do or the type of
reaction
i'm picking up another i'm just picking
up random name reactions here just for
the sake of having something to talk
about
yeah
it's good to do this i mean
we find out what the breadth of the
weirdness is out there right
well so this case is fairly
straightforward that's a single pattern
variable
yep
yeah
let's see here yeah here's another one
it looks like uh
our friend mr
corey seems to have a bunch of reactions
that um
he will have one nobody knows
yeah
those fashions the nobel prize will do
that
yeah
um yeah but he seems to be a single
radical kind of kind of guy from what
i'm saying
he was crusty from what i heard yes yeah
still around i think he's still around i
think he's still alive
yes
yeah he's he's my academic grandfather
by the way
oh okay
maybe i should meet him before while
he's still around the
um okay let's look at another case here
the one you just had is probably not a
good example because it's uh multiple
ones right uh there's a bracket square
back but we have no representation yet
what what is that what does that mean
the square record yeah what does that
mean
it's an intermediate that's not isolated
yeah so we don't have a presentation for
that so
i don't understand what what do you i
don't understand what it means is it it
just means
what does it mean it's still a molecule
right it's got something
it is
but it's not isolated
when you're doing that reaction that
thing forms but you don't bother
isolating it because you that you
quickly do the next step which is the
one with mercury to get the final breath
okay but do we care about i mean there's
that's just an annotation of that graph
that says we didn't isolate it okay so
in this case yeah
absolutely freaking bizarrely uh michael
one circle microstructures which are a
different beast together what do you
mean what is this marco structures
basically mean that that r1 can be
attached anywhere in the benzene ring we
don't we're not we don't really care
where it's attached it's attached
somewhere
it's used very often in patents
so you get to cover the universe
okay so explain what it means so there's
a bunch of hydrogens hanging off that
benzene ring right this is an
alternative this is going to substitute
for one of those
exactly exactly for any of the four
right
by four we mean the ones that weren't
otherwise attached
well there are four there are four
hydrogens on that ring that are
available no i i guess i get it i guess
i'm just i'm just saying that that um
okay
so
okay is that a specific thing
relevant to hydrogens that they that
they you can lock them off and put these
substitutions in or is that could that
could there be another case where you
could lop off
another i mean is that um no only
hydrogens
are
like that yeah microstructures tend to
basically
assume you can replace the hydrogen with
any of a bunch of things in this case
they are working okay let me pick
another one here this one looks totally
horrifying
um
you also notice here that they're using
a pre-superscript or a post-superscript
to differentiate the r's and other
places people use primes yeah i see that
i mean i see that so basically
subscripts it's a mess
right which means we've got to basically
allow them to use arbitrary names
in my opinion and the fact that smarts
only has a particular set of names is
you know well that's the way that is but
okay
is this interesting or is this just some
weird thing with a with electrochemistry
or something
it's similar to the diels-alder that we
were looking at last week to be honest
but
okay a little more flexible because
those a's are usually heteroatoms and
not not carbons
pick up one charge is there right so
we're doing the representation as well
yeah
i'm i'm just seeing some here that look
just like the other ones
um
a lot of other ones here that are just
that's kind of a cool one
that's a that looks just like you see
i'm i'm i'm still
that's just like this is a um
t-channel channel
you like that right cycle edition
and then
decomposition but in a different
direction
what does the squiggly mean what does
that squiggly line mean
sis or trans
yeah
it could be to the left or to the right
right
it doesn't matter for this case
what does that mean i mean what what
what when you said to the left
do you okay you could draw to the left
the way it is or you could draw it to
the right
alternatively and those are different
three-dimensional geometries so the
double bond is not rotatable so uh when
you have uh the atoms on either side of
a double bond they stay there they don't
rotate around so so you can um
so they behave differently depending on
whether they're on the same side
you can separate them they have
different melting points different
boiling points right
okay all right so let's come back to
what we're doing here so
what we've got is a variety of ways in
which you can wild card out
pieces of a molecule basically that's
what this is telling us and that
including this rather weird one here
take a
a sub graph
well it's a
all these things it's not really a
subgraph all these things are things
where you break a single bond and you
can put something else on at the other
end of it
first statement
mostly uh some of them you you create
bonds uh where none existed before like
the uh
i'm just talking about the pattern i'm
talking about the representation of the
pattern not talking about what happens
in the reaction talking about what the
pattern is because in
okay so in normal expression patterns
you know
what we have is that a sub graph
as a subtree
is a wild card
you get what i'm saying um if i write
something
so here
this is a form of
pattern graph pattern
help me out here i'm i'm
the thing that's confusing me okay i
know what's confusing me
every single example we're seeing here
the
um
the
the wild card piece the pattern piece
the blank piece is hanging off the end
that is we don't see one of these r's
that's in the middle
to go not in these examples but
sometimes you do you do see that uh for
example
the ring might be variable size could be
five six seven eight membered rings so
you'll see
n with per uh
around one vertex of the ring with an uh
subscript your parentheses around the
vertex with an n meaning a variable
number of okay but i'm trying to see
okay graph rewriting you know
traditional graph rewriting
involves you take a sub graph of one
graph somewhere in the middle of the
graph
and you rewrite it to some other
subgraph
yes most of what we're seeing here is a
very special case of that
where we have a thing hanging off the
end of edge of the graph and we don't
have to worry about how this thing
reconnects in because it it just has
this one connection and it's just going
to you know that's the to to change
what's here
we're just
you know we're just putting yeah we're
putting a different thing that we don't
have to we don't have to describe it
other pieces of connection
right it has just one hair
i'm trying to think of an example where
we've got two or more hairs that get
replaced
but the thing gets replaced that would
be an edta ligand
represented by an r group that has two
or three bonds from the r oh yeah
that works
tell me what that is can i look that up
eat
oh
yeah edta should probably get it by
googling yes
um
uh what is it ethylene diamine
ethylenediamine
okay well i mean with that presumably we
have that
if i say control edta
then have it yeah there we go
and now we just no that's not it no
that's it that's that's another name for
it
for though that's what doe calls it
anyway
yeah that's the stuff that's it yep
that's it
okay so now where's the
where's the um what do we do with this
creature so if you remove the hydrogens
off of the um oxygens then all six
oxygens can form bonds to a metal
okay or other other things so here is a
here's a functional group that you could
represent by r and the r would up
potentially make up to six bonds to the
other thing that it's bound to
i see
okay
so so in other words in one of these
diagrams there are multiple bonds coming
out of the r
there could be yeah yeah especially for
inorganic chemistry
often too
so we have charles here i think
and you guys were saying you know i was
saying you take a molecule and worst
cases you convert it to a graph and then
you do computations on it and you
immediately said we can't do that
because graph does not preserve
annotations no no i immediately said
that molecule is a graph like when we do
computations on it we are doing graph
computations yeah and i also said that
graph itself if i tried to build a
molecule
with a graph
and put annotations on the vertices and
the edges as soon as i do something like
graph disjoint union i lose them all
okay so i want to put two pieces
together two molecules together charles
can you comment on that
um white
so
um is not yet implemented in short so we
did uh support of annotation or the
inheritance
you know calculus of inheritance for
univariate operations so
and we haven't yet done that for
you know
operations okay so you believe your
calculus of annotations is complete for
unary operations
is that right that it preserves
correctly yes
okay so we can consider it essentially a
bug but it is not correctly preserving
annotations for for emery operations is
that right yes
okay so
okay
fine well hopefully that can get fixed
you know quickly but it sounds like
sounds like you have people with
pitchforks clamoring for that to get
fixed charles
okay
we'll make sure we have it in
soon
any chance for 13 1
um
no with the time table of snow
no
okay but
um
well we can look at you know if there's
some specific operation we can probably
you know focus on those but you know
we're going to do bob can you specify
that which ones or any of the rest of
you specify that
uh which ones lose the annotations
no no which ones do you really care
about them i mean if charles is going to
make sure they don't lose the
annotations which ones do you really
care about first not you know if charles
is going to go fix these sequentially
which one should he fix first
to do molecules i would want vertex and
annotations on vertices and annotations
about the operations bob
which operations
currently lose the annotations because
what charles claims is that unary graph
operations do not lose annotations
i i would have to look and see i i i do
know that crap this joint union does it
because i ran into that a few weeks ago
okay
charles is saying none of the non-unary
operations preserve annotations okay
he's asking for a priority list of which
nra operations should he prioritize
first in preserving the annotations i
will supply him one by the end of today
okay sounds good
um okay but let's come back to this
question about how we represent and and
we're over time unfortunately here but
but um uh and we really need to solve
this problem um i mean you know i'm
telling you this is going to need a
little bit of slightly heavier lifting
than we're applying right now because
it's clear that there are a bunch of
cases and you know what what is also
clear is some of these look challenging
i mean is there a smart representation
of this thing here so so i think i think
it's a mistake to jump to the name
reactions because i've looked through
these
and a large percentage of them i think
won't be representable as like as a
template reaction object or what
whatever we end up calling it like some
of them you might need a whole function
to represent that that reaction and it
might involve several temp
uh
several reaction chemical
transformations or whatever we want to
call it
um
but the the the object i'm trying to
present is is
is a a discrete operation it's it does
something and it does that thing but it
doesn't do everything it doesn't i i
know but we need a representation of a
molecular pattern or whatever you're
going to call it something which has
you know we've got these different cases
we've got the case with substitutions
we've got the case with functional
groups you know with arbitrary
functional groups
those are two known cases
and
you know
we want something that can represent you
know we have a we we have lots of
experience with having a pattern
language for expressions
okay let's make use of that experience
the one thing we don't have good
experience with yet
is a pattern language for graphs
or any atomic object right i mean
once it's atomic
it's not open to the pattern matcher no
no i i understand that but what i'm
saying is we need a definition of
pattern matching that works okay
we might have a definition of pattern
matching that works for graphs we're
close but we don't have that quite
maybe charles and or nick wants to say
something about that charles can you say
something about what you've thought
about in that regard
well i can't go more precisely but we
you know we are working proposal and
trying to write some prototype to see
how the whole thing works so
still under development okay pretty much
okay but i mean you know in the physics
project we have lots of experience with
graph rewriting and however the
convenient form of graph rewriting is
much more this hyper graph thing
um but i i you know
i have lots of code for graphic writing
from the 1990s
that
in fact
we should look at again because it uses
pattern variables and so on to represent
uh
you know
to do the obvious kinds of things
um
okay but but
you know what what you're trying to do
here
is
you're trying to
name
okay
one type of transformation of graphs
is one where you're merely trying to
trace where the nodes go
and one of the confusing things is that
we actually have two different i mean we
have a perfectly good
canonical representation of that carbon
okay independent of your one arrow
carbon that carbon
is
a certain atom number in our molecule
representation is it not that's the
thing that says bond one two
means it's the atom it's atom number one
bonded to atom number two right yes
yes okay so what's a little bit crazy
weird here is that we're adding another
layer i mean we could name
this
you know this thing on the right hand
side has a perfectly good canonical name
we don't need the one arrow see there's
no new information here
correct
but it would be a double layout one
would be three four
what do you mean so i mean in this case
here what we're saying is
that
you know they're like they're like the
the the carbon you just had it
do not one it would be one one
because it's from the first molecule
pattern
i mean you're saying right you're saying
that we have to label
which i see so i i understand so you're
saying the okay
atoms
need to be labeled
with
which
atom number they are
in a given molecule
choice and which molecule they come
right
[Music]
and i would love to get away from
positional notation well i mean so
actually to be honest i was thinking
about making it even more positional
like not so right there you have this
one goes to c
so you're putting the the mapping inside
the patterns the labels you could also
make the mapping itself an option to the
template reaction and there it would be
list one comma one goes to
one comma one and what that means is the
first atom from the first reactant
becomes the first atom in this in the
first product
see it's that's for computation i find
that for manual work
version of writing these things in
manually by hand that is convenient or
nice it's going to be like drawing it
is the only way that i think that's
going to make it well i'm not convinced
i'm not convinced
we have a problem
look
in a situation like this
that's i mean
we don't you know that notation is
perfectly reasonable whether it
semantically makes sense i don't know
but that notation for patterns
you know doesn't seem completely crazy
to me
right so i i mean as you like the the
farthest one down on the left i mean i
could parse that
and turn it into essentially
internally something like
the other forms we've seen well i mean
what's interesting about that is it
would allow you in a molecule pattern if
you want to have a radical i mean then
then we could use the full pattern
language
just say
you know i mean you could even do
something like you know this and you
could say and you could have something
where you in other words where that
that's what how you would write
name it a and it's a cnn or no
or
right and you could stick a condition on
that or you could stick a pattern test
right yes and that's the problem because
i'm not actually calling the pattern
matcher
well that's a technical implementation
i don't know the pattern
to handle like condition and pattern
test and alternative and all those
things and everything that molecule
pattern would
cover i would i need to write down
values on verbatim blank stop
stop worrying about that okay
look the right way to do that is all the
simple cases you just handle directly in
some complicated case perhaps what we do
is we throw it at some future graph free
writing
you know full pattern language system
okay
you're making
you know this this
protect because of implementation
difficulty is the wrong thing
let's not worry about the implantation
we can also say oh you can't put you
know it just doesn't work yet
sorry we don't support that yet
get what i'm saying
but if it turns out it's the right thing
conceptually then this is where we
should go now in this case of of you
know a blank
that seems like that's a pretty good way
to represent your star type r thing
right and it also allows you to get
the case that is i think rather
important which is the r blank r blank
versus r colon blank blank
or just you know in other words you can
say whether you need those things to be
the same
yeah
oh yeah
you know one one difficulty
one thing we have to be aware of is you
could use a pattern within
part of your atom specification
and you could
you know for like you have here for for
a uh being c n rho and on the right hand
side
you should only use that in one place
that a
and it should really
mean the whole atom and everything else
about it
uh and not just the the atomic symbol
part
what other things might there be about
it uh the formal charge number of
unpaired electrons
how do you represent the formal charge
how do we represent formal charge it's
an it's an absolute yeah it's an option
of an atom
actually so instead of c
c comma quote formal charge quote goes
to one or minus one is it quotes formal
charge why is it quotes
because we don't have a fine symbol for
it
okay
then what do you call that jason
an annotation
okay fine it's an annotation
it's not an option because
you don't have to call i mean you can't
call set options on it
okay right and that's right it never
made sense for me to call it an option
okay
and we don't have a formal charge symbol
in the system
yeah
but there's there's formal charge uh
there's mass number
yeah unpaired electron count
those sorts of things uh
get carried along
some of them we would a reaction would
change
okay we still haven't solved this
problem and we're running into uh i'm
30 minutes late the one thing i would be
a little bit concerned it's a variation
would trace and say like the condition
on one is very sensible and probably
implementable but you can make the
condition on the whole left-hand side
and then it becomes a nightmare
ever never be solvable fine fine okay
but i don't think look
okay
to me
again my initial reaction to this to
this reaction stuff
would be
that this is a this is a better approach
than this i think by the time we've got
two different kinds of numbering running
around
it just feels like we're just gonna get
everything totally confused
now
you know the other point of view would
be to say
that
um
nobody will ever type these things in
like this
they'll type them in as smart strings or
draw them or something like that and
therefore we should not obsess we should
make we should put more emphasis on
making this these things be kind of
formally clean and correct
than we should and whether they're
typeable
do you get what i'm saying mm-hmm
okay so i want to kind of understand
in the perfect formally correct version
of this what would you like to do
because one of the things that's
difficult here is if i take this
molecule apart
and put it back together again all these
numbers are going to be scrambled
same thing i could say about a graph a
graph
like this has you know if i have the
vertices and edges of a graph i better
keep those in sync or everything's going
to be scrambled
right that's what's happening here these
are the vertices and edges of
essentially a graph
and so
so my question is i mean michael is
saying it's very inelegant
to have something that
is sort of telling
you know referencing
atoms by their positional you know by
their molecule number and position
within the molecule
but my question would be is that i would
not say inelegant
okay
it's reasonably elegant but like my
favorite example is like i have a grit
and i want to make some rose green
and the fact that i cannot do this in
line that i have to by the end in an
option
dynamically count where i am i find yeah
it's horrifying terrifying and by the
way that's the thing that we should put
in the ild meeting to talk about that um
but
but yes but but the point is here
annotatability
in place annotatability is very nice
when we can get it
right so clearly we've blown some up
already by the fact that our atoms and
our bonds are in separate lists that
have to be kept in sync
yes
yeah again
so now the question is if you want to
annotate something so you've got
something annotated as a pattern
and you know might you want to annotate
a bond
with a name
yeah because bond orders can change in a
reaction
yeah
or can disappear altogether
okay so no so i i but i don't think you
would want to give it a name
why
well so i could i mean all three of the
examples that they just gave are you
wouldn't need that right so if you want
to change the bond order the bond order
you just write a bond and you say which
indices it is and you give it a new bond
order or if you want to bond to
discipline
you give it a new bundle that as and you
write it out
in a different sequence
in the right hand side moment in the
products yeah okay
and then if you want a bond to disappear
then you just it just isn't in the
bondless yeah i would also think atoms
and bonds are not at the same footing
one would think so right i mean bonds
are a much more ephemeral kind of
creature
um
but
okay
so the issue is you want to be able to
label but okay here's the tricky thing
with this functional group thing you are
basically making a phone
faux atom a fake atom
are you not this r
is you're you're handling it like an
atom but it isn't really an atom yeah in
some context we call them dummy atoms
okay fine
or it's sort of the uh
around equivalent for an atom there's an
uncertainty of what it is
okay that's even yeah but that's even
more complicated concept because
i mean to me
okay but basically what you're saying is
i can take a graph that represents a
molecule i can chop one of the atoms out
and i can replace it
by
some functional group that has the same
bond configuration as that atom had
is that right that would be lovely
yeah yes
yes
especially for manipulating chemical
structures to design new ones
i don't know if we would have a reaction
that necessarily does that but
it's a it's an operation that's very
reasonable
okay so in other words an atom is
removed so it's it's like in in a graph
replacement setting
this is a case where the sub graph that
you're operating on is a trivial
subgraph it's just a single vertex
and what you're doing is
you're you're simply replacing
you know it's the most trivial kind of
graph replacement now currently
as i understand it and charles can maybe
speak to this vertex replace just
replaces one vertex by another vertex
correct it can't replace the vertex by a
sub graph
yes correct
just the vertex
right okay but but the most trivial form
of graph rewriting that
that doesn't have to address many of the
kind of hairiness hair issues
is you've got a single vertex you
replace it with another vertex that has
the same connections as that first
vertex add
but you just reinsert something with
that same collection of connections is
is that right that's that's that's the
chemistry chemically interesting case
yep
yes
okay all right so fine so then then what
we need
is something in molecule or molecule
pattern
that
uh you know is basically going to be a a
potentially
you know in something like this
you know we might want a pure blank here
or we might want
something that is more complicated it
might be a blank
with the condition that
its atomic radius is less than something
or other
or is that totally crazy
radius not it isn't really
so bad
right so you can write a to like atom
open close uh formal charge goes to
greater than two
if you're looking for an atom like that
right
formal charge how do i oh i see that it
goes to greater than
two okay the example i was giving was
more extreme i mean i have to believe
that in one of these friendly chelates
or whatever
um okay in a zeolite i have to believe
it's got a cage of a certain size and so
in principle you could say you know any
atom that fits in that cage
yeah right and so you can imagine
extending the current notation to have
the rule uh atomic radius goes to
less than
blah or something right right or
alternatively
in this other notation
i could just have a condition here that
says
uh you know atomic radius of of uh
a2
blah blah blah
if that makes sense
right if i say here
a2
bracket well it's not quite a2 it's it's
some
some entity value thing on a2
with a condition
but okay that's
so irrelevant i think the main point
here is
that what we want is a pattern variable
let's see
yeah i mean i don't understand why this
isn't a good idea but by the way
the other type of kind of um
you know faux pattern is a string
pattern
right we've already done a bunch of
these things you know using pattern
language constructs
with slight extensions and removals to
deal with strings
and what what's happened with
biosequences do they not use those
things as well
they use string like patterning
yes
internal in for some for some of the
string related functions internally the
you can apply regex for example on the
string as shown by the biosequence
okay it's fine
right that's okay but but the sequences
itself have their own letters to
designate alternatives
but what i'm saying is we're using the
syntactic structure of the pattern
matcher
while having some special casing
for you know
you know base pair substitutions and
things like this
yes so we've already got a precedent for
doing that so i think we should continue
that precedent for molecules
which strongly supports using something
that is essentially a pattern match of
syntax here
um
and then simply defining how far you can
go with the with the pattern syntax
within molecules
and there may be plenty of things where
people know never ask the question and
never care and the fact that you can't
have a weird you know conditional a
double blank for example
you know you might actually want to
double blank in your extensible ring
scenario you might want a double blank
if i'm not mistaken
we we might yeah
but
yeah in in this particular notation that
would be hard because it's both vertices
and edges
or bound atoms and bonds that would be
sequenced good example that's a good
example of why you can't do that um
listen i really need to go to a
different meeting um and uh
uh
we need to continue this um
we're making progress we're not quite
there yet
if you guys have a chance to talk about
it separately i i
my my
my suggestion is
think how we can leverage pattern
matcher
semantics
as much as possible
jason
don't worry too much about the fact that
corner cases are
okay well i'm perfectly i'm i'm
perfectly okay just giving an error
message in those cases
does that make sense
jason yes
okay i lost his internet or he's freaked
out
um
the okay
um
okay i have to run but let's try to
continue this
soon please
because i know we need to get this
nailed down very quickly
yep
um
thank you
okay thanks